good morning everyone i thought that i
would start my day today uh with a cup
of tea and catching up on the nintendo
direct mini partner showcase that aired
yesterday um i actually knew about this
one ahead of time
because parts of sonic frontiers were
embargoed specifically for this direct
so i'm assuming that there is sonic in
this direct otherwise i have no idea
what's in it very excited it feels like
it uh it was definitely due
and it's interesting they're calling it
mini it is 26 minutes long that's not
that short so other than sonic which i'm
expecting to see
um finally actually get to show off the
previously leaked cyber world stuff
which was the coolest part of the game
when i played it at summer game fest by
a mile it's so weird that it was embargo
just for the direct when it was already
leaked but yeah outside of that i don't
know what's going to be in here this is
obviously not going to be anything first
party
probably expect some stuff from square i
think we can probably expect some more
details on previously announced games
i'm excited let's do it
i respect the hell out of that
i don't need this life
way too
bright in the morning
[Music]
make myself smaller
when mankind is consumed by darkness and
the land falls into chaos
the archdemon of the abyss shall rise
from the earth
they come rushing here in a desperate
attempt to survive
both beast and man have more in common
than they think if this was dragon's dog
with two coming to switch i would lose
my mind
but i would lose my mind
just the way that the map looked and
that castle looks so much like it looks
a dragon stopper
[Music]
is so epic
such epic
monster trailers the music
and also i've said this before
but the whole time
i'm always just looking at these beasts
and being like i'ma wear that [ __ ] as a
skirt
can't wait to put you on as a cape my
friend the story ends
another begins
wandering flames
[Music]
i see you found pretty
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like this trailer makes it look
very final fantasy
what is that a minigun i don't know you
could do that
wow
i also just love a colorful video game
the variety of uh
environments in most hunters
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's very pretty
excuse me
but can you imagine if that were dragon
stock
[Applause]
i do not uh actively play monster hunter
i have multiple times in the past i know
it's very successful capcom but um
it's hard for any game to keep me even
with updates for uh
years
very little that i will play figures
seething basil geese goose
rare species and subspecies monsters
several monsters
[Laughter]
i respect the hell out of the support
they're giving it though
massive expansion coming june
30. oh cool i might play that
love a demo
hello everyone welcome to today's
nintendo direct mini partner showcase in
this presentation we'll be focusing on
nintendo switch games launching this
year from our publishing and development
partners
okay let's get into the headlines i like
that
the battle approach reclaim earth begins
the year is 50 12 a.d
machine life forms have overwhelmed the
planet causing the collapse of
stabilization and forcing humans to take
refuge on the moon
hell yeah now with an android squad
called jorge the humans are prepared
near automata is one of my favorite
games ever made absolutely adore this
game if you have not played it 2b give
it a try
and a scanner android though i do think
it's one of those ones that i have to
recommend you play it for like several
hours before you give up
a lot of people give up on the like
opening mission of mia because they died
it forms in conflict it's so good it's
so smart
it's like what will come a very
interesting approach to non-linear
storytelling but also
maintaining like a
character that you can follow in a
linear way of the award-winning near
automata comes with previous automata
content including additional modes and
costumes nice
nice exclusive to the nintendo switch
version will also be available very cool
reclaim earth in near automata the end
of your edition launching on the
nintendo switch system october 6th such
a good game again today on nintendo
eshop
i don't know that i need to play it
again but um i'm excited for a lot of
you who haven't
to try it
a maze of deceptions
a murder mystery
i'm trying to do it like a trailer voice
guy but i'm actually just doing it like
twilight zone guy
my voice doesn't go that deep
get ready to immerse yourself in surreal
riddles and a chilling story in this
modern take on puzzle adventure games
this is pretty looking
i'm intrigued
[Music]
solve the enigma of lorelei and the
laser eyes launching first stylish
trailer very stylish switch next year
[Music]
familiar faces are making a splash in
these games
in these games
[Music]
a new probably a kingdom uh battle
nintendo switch in this time a bombastic
new mode called castle mode enters the
fray a team of up to 15 players must
blast their way to treasure chests maybe
konomi is still making video games
oh my gosh set up your defense wisely to
blow away opponents literally you can
also create and share your own battle
stages have a blast when super bomberman
r2 launches on nintendo switch next year
10 mega man battle network games
originally released on the game boy
advance system are coming to nintendo
switch
control mega man in grid-based combat
you never played any of these
devastating abilities i played mega man
games but i've never played with over 1
000 illustrations and a music mode
containing over and fifty this
particular series that's the series
mega man battle network legacy
collection launches on nintendo switch
next year
the full collection will also be
digitally available as volume one and
volume two each sold separately
a remake of pac-man world is coming soon
pac-man's family has been kidding
to rescue them he sets off for ghost
island eating dots isn't all you can do
here
trounce enemies with pack dots the
reverel
a giant man pacman punching somebody in
the face which is like a slow like
sock is very funny levels save the pack
fan in pac-man world repack launching on
nintendo switch august 26th
[Music]
two unlikely friends oh that's pretty
one incredible journey i'm interested
a fawn and a wolf cub must work together
to find a way home across the snowy
wilderness
in the handcrafted world of blanc
oh it might be
in this emotional adventure gorgeous
these unlikely friends must coordinate
and use their individual strengths to
solve environmental puzzles and navigate
through the frigid wilds
blanc is a completely text-free story
with local and online co-op play awesome
players can enjoy it
how cool
into this very into this
co-op
forge an unexpected bond in blanc
wow
that looks very sweet launching as a
consequence exclusive on nintendo switch
february 2023. nice the pacing of this
so far is wild by the way
so fast a swashbuckling adventure
returns
eyes monkey island
pirating is in my monkey island for sure
like adrenaline or stale grog i can't
believe this game's being made enough
scraps to fill a dozen scrapbooks it
like
feels like such like chips the games
industry miracle love treasure betrayal
and root beer but how about one that has
all of the above
my name is guy brush three i just never
this is a story expected
to make
the secret of monkey island
another monkey island
and to have it be the same talent and
not just like an ip that somebody's
milking
is so so so cool
guy brush three wood
[Music]
that man just deep throated that sausage
wow
it's too early for this
[Music]
i bet this game's gonna be so [ __ ]
good
like it's almost guaranteed
try not to like ever convince myself of
that with any video games these days but
dude i bet you this is gonna be awesome
the colors are gorgeous i love the art
style
ah
it's so exciting that means it's coming
out this year i feel like i didn't know
that i knew it was coming but i feel
like i missed a release date monkey
return to monkey island i will thank you
on nintendo switch this year
next we have some news about a game that
was announced last june
please take a look
okay mario and the rabbit's blasting
battle here's an adventure in the latest
mario plus rabbits game
space is in a universe of trouble when
other worldly enemies suddenly appear
their goal
take the energy possessed by sparks
these mysterious creatures
now our heroes must set out to save them
i really enjoyed the questions
you'll initiate a turn-based battle when
you encounter an enemy it can also be
really challenging like before we begin
here's some kinder battle had a lot of
stages that go real quickly move around
the battlefield as much as you'd like
within your character's range
interesting using their weapon
pretty neat huh
hmm let's start with mario
three enemies are in there are you gonna
give mario a gun
[Music]
now select rabbit rosalina and have her
dash into another terrifying
next rabid luigi
this crossover even exists it's so
disturbing
by using a dash first then the weapon
three enemies were wiped out with that
his turn i wonder if that'll make it a
whole lot easier or
definitely just gotta balance let's take
out the other two
pew pew
that concludes his turn you can't give
mario guns you got you can't be doing
that at least rabbit rosalina team up
with an ally he hasn't had him before
but it makes me deeply uncomfortable
get positioned then finish off with the
kaboomer
kabooma okay our turns what is he going
to yell at me on facebook
and now the enemy attacks be sure to
take cover and you might be safe
if you don't it won't be pretty
alright we've got the floor again
dash toward the bomb
and if you chuck it over
boom
that'll do it
the key to victory is how you ass it's
interesting it should play like failing
differently with all that considered
wait
i'm glad to see it it's not just the
exact same thing the team
also music by grant cochran friend of
the show
rockets onto the nintendo switch system
october 20th pre-orders begin today on
nintendo eshop it looks good it looks
good check out ubisoft's special
showcase tomorrow for more details about
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
[Music]
we hope you're looking forward to the
chaotic adventures of mario and the
rabbits thanks let's take a look at more
headlines hey thanks
let's take a look at more headlines
there's something for everyone a
nintendo switch
during a storm young alchemist noah
crashed in ancient ruins
the layout of these multi-layered ruins
changes every time you enter them
recruit allies called lilliputs to
challenge the enemies lurking around
every corner string together combos and
perform powerful elemental attacks to
defeat foes
little noah scion of paradise launches a
nintendo switch later today
oh
wow just gonna drop that like that
in the management sim braille grade
you'll build railway systems to
efficiently transport cargo it's very
pretty restore economic prosperity to an
industrial college i hate to admit that
i would probably [ __ ] love this game
prepare each shipment i would probably
have a very good time playing the train
game these will change based on various
factors like the number and length of
trains to run
which resources to acquire
and how to transport cargo from point a
to point b
rail grade steam rolls onto nintendo's
witch this fall
joint aspiring game creator kenta in a
hand-drawn adventure to save the world
in his latest creation the legend i'm so
impressed by the variety of art we've
seen in this book this rpg spans over
200 pages where you must draw
erase
solve puzzles and even consult your
handy calculator cute discover a new way
to yeah i feel like this has been so
many
different distinct art styles from some
of these small games right unfolds onto
nintendo switch august 18th
pre-orders begin today
video games you know what a blessing
who'd have thought
spin dash into a new zone all right this
is gonna be it
sonic's latest action adventure kicks
off on the vibrancy curious i did play
the game i did a q a about it uh last
week here it's on the channel where i
answered a bunch of questions vast open
zone taking full advantage of sonic's
speedies interesting that they try not
to call it an open world it's such a
strange choice they keep saying it's not
an open world but attack enemies it sure
feels like one open zone gather attacks
to trigger combos and rack up damage
with good timing you can even deflect
enemy attacks
acquires trying to fight that thing i
didn't have enough skills arsenal of
moves yeah it has like a proper skill
system
you can also enter a special zone called
cyberspace so cyberspace did leak take
on chips the cyberspace sonic speeds was
really fun and grabbed keys to progress
and really felt like sonic and i hope
that it's very prevalent in front
because yeah the cyber cyber space stuff
was like the
the best part of the game sonic on these
strange islands
sonic frontiers dashes onto nintendo
switch this holiday
[Music]
live magically alongside your disney and
pixar friends
i was really expecting to see a bunch of
swearing stuff for some reason idyllic
land where disney and pixar characters
lived in harmony until the forgetting
turned this dream into a nightmare what
is this kingdom fought it's up to you to
help these iconic residents recover
their lost memories and reveal the
secrets that led you here
bring the magic back it's like a sims
kingdom hawks mesmerizing i mean it
doesn't look like santa hats in terms of
gameplay at all
many different characters unfortunately
very interesting with heroes and
villains alike
everyone you meet will have personal
stories to discover what is this
complete help them out by exploring
giving them gifts and performing other
fun activities it's like a survival game
you can be whoever you dream yourself
what the [ __ ] is this
disney dreamlight valley launches on
nintendo switch september 6th as an
early access title that's really
interesting
what in the gameplay adventures with you
on the go as opposed to what you could
do that with all of them live alive is
coming alive on july 22nd oh my god
finally how exciting is featuring
different protagonists time periods and
gameplay
[Music]
will be gamepl finally being playable
today
is such a big deal the demo can be
transferred to the full game once
purchased
deraimon nobi and their friends land on
an unknown planet and decide to help a
new friend fulfill his dreams by farming
plow the fields harvest crops
and tend to the animals
you can even use duraimon's secret
gadgets to farm in a flash
relax by living with friends eating
delicious meals
and it's very cute and with local play
you and a pal can build a ranch together
deraimon story of seasons friends of the
great kingdom launches on the nintendo
switch system this year
that's like a
the world of minecraft meets like an
extra cute minecraft legends
[Music]
surrounded by rich nature is invaded by
enemies from another dimension
team up with allies and fight against
this monstrous force threatening the
world i think i will also probably try
this game
it seems like it's a survival minecraft
legend minecraft on nintendo switch and
i play virtually every survival game
that comes out at least for a little bit
um put a lot of time in about hunter's
paradise
but i'll play it on pc i'm sorry i'm
collecting grand treasures from around
the world
venture to the realm of draconia to
become legendary treasure hunters
in this dragon quest series spin-off
you'll recruit a variety of
well-mannered monsters to join you i've
never played a dragon quest game with
their help and with your trusty
relationship
locating loot will be a breeze not even
one time monsters are perfect travel
buddies for exploring this vast world
bounce on a slime to reach high ledges
or dangle from a draky to glide over
gaping chasms
support your monsters in battle as they
fearlessly fend off foes
bring your hard-earned haul back to your
base and see how much it's worth it's
evil
and increase spyros treasure hunting
level x marks the spot when dragon quest
treasures launches on nintendo switch
december 9th the pacing of this is so
impressive there is a lot in this
conference
[Music]
nice cuts there whoever edited this
got a bunch of friends playing that
right now
[Music]
so nuts that that's on switch
it could eat so much of my time being
portable
yeah excited to check out more of the
the cloud-based stuff too
this which is like such an interesting
trial for
more cloud-based gaming
[Music]
give me images like that i don't even
know where the dog is right now he's
probably chewing my shoes somewhere
oh
can you imagine if this is how they
announced portal 3 i'd cry
i mean it's not but can you imagine if
this is how they did it
there might even be cake
the portal companion collection will be
available later today
i wanted to call it the why do you keep
killing me collection
but oh well
[Music]
i genuinely think portal 1 and 2 are the
best games ever made
i will argue that point
they are perfect video farm
fight
and forge friendships in a new fantasy
world
welcome to leafy a peaceful village
where seasons brightly color the
environment
your story begins here in this brand new
life simulation rpg
a lot of farming stuff
cooking craft
items and trek through the fields to
collect that's gorgeous
[Music]
all while meeting townsfolk along the
way
the seasons gently flow from spring
summer fall and winter
[Music]
however
they will give way to the season of
death
quietus
that's so cheesy
life is threatened
i very much like to look at this stop
the season of death from wreaking havoc
on your home
[Music]
the fate of the village depends as
somebody who always tries to play a mage
in every video game
[Music]
that looks sick
this next segment i'm very down
announcement please take a look okay i
will
mission
start can you imagine if this is how
they pronounce announced persona 6
hey mogana
i'm morgana reigning ace of the phantom
thieves apart
and today i'm bringing along an ultra
top secret video
we will steal you
that's man atlas really just getting out
there
xbox 2 look at them go
[Music]
[Applause]
persona 5 is
so fantastic such a good game
did not play royal i did play a little
bit on this but i didn't finish 21st
hell yeah that's not all yeah let's keep
the ball rolling
teddy
[Music]
nice baton pass morgana
okay everyone
i guess it'll probably all the same
content that uh xbox is getting
[Music]
bear leave it persona 4 golden and
persona 3 portable are also coming
very cool for a lot of people very good
video games
very excited
for everybody who gets to experience
them for the first time this year both
on xbox and nintendo on nintendo switch
more persona you say that's all for
today's nintendo direct mini partner
showcase thank you for watching
my pleasure
i really enjoyed this
um
i love the way they pace the the directs
i guess the mini direct is like no cuts
to people at all
so so so fast like i said a lot of like
very
gorgeous art variety
and definitely a lot of games i'm
interested in and the fact that these
are all in the next 12 months is
actually kind of scary if anything i'm
like wow
do i have time for all this i guess i'll
figure it out